okay so we have a lot of fun but then we
had this crazy idea where everyone would
be shooting on one person and the only
way we could make it fair it's not fair
but is if one person wears a mask and
they can move as fast as they want and
they just have to cross that line so I'm
going first
that's so cool next time I configure
what does this they're here we go oh
okay oh boy you're in Samara yes there
there's going to be a swamp hey here's a
good some nail everybody just like this
I would alga now water at one point I
just closed my eyes and attached paint
then I spun her I never seem to be
amazed like all right oh yeah right oh
yeah oh thank you still on man come on
oh oh I didn't get him ya know something
rise up Robo guys what's up I'm trying
everything you can do it come on just
good the real why did you get hit by
arrows I got busy got it all when Rick
I forgot to put it this way
no China that is how you do it why did
the way that you do it first show like
right on your mark man no slobber Adam
skin remember jumping spin almost done
oh when you're gonna yeah one more
well we run out we win me on me huh yeah
give you shot what you have shot one I'm
getting tired open this thing oh oh nice
real arrows you didn't do it off the bat
come on T then I'm so fresh you can suck
- warmer by world
other clothes what to check with Jeremy
now I get a wolf sense all right Matt I
did it last one you like here we go
change
that's what you guys do it oh that's
scary it's so scary
oh he go for get up guys I don't like
you oh I think if we don't hit him
broken dude you gotta hit him got a Matt
maybe I don't why markiplier night-night
I have nothing to prove right re1 no yet
this Rosa with Rosa flew the first time
it was a fluke we weren't all likes it
you like some of us deny to show you
yeah like Fred Astaire
I ran more nervous now than I was before
because we really want to do
ready see the lab all oh man guys what
are you owe me so bad merci merci the
workout huh I was going as hard as it
could I had some good does a couple
times in Jessup yet okay so that was the
nerf arrow dodging whatever red light
green light channel off zing bow sorry
thank you everybody for joining me team
edge and thighs man Ryan hi anything
bigger and if you guys enjoyed this
video and want to see more cool stuff
like it we had a ton of fun let us know
in the comments below leave a like if
you enjoyed the video and thanks again
everybody for watching and as always
we'll see you next one bye bye bye bye
look it up see you guys yeah